the European Union is urging Iran to
stick by its commitments under the
nuclear deal agreed with world powers in
2015 the statement was given ahead of
the ongoing EU summit in the Romanian
city of CBU where the 27 EU heads of
state are gathered to outline a new
strategic agenda for the European
Union's in a joint declaration European
leaders stated that they rejected
ultimatums from Tehran but vowed to
fight to save the Iran nuclear deal
let's hear what French president
Emmanuel macron just said about leaving
the nuclear agreement of 2015 would be a
mistake
it would mean unraveling all past
achievements that's why France is
staying and will stay I hope Iran
decides to do this thing it's up to us
to convince everyone including Iran to
stick to the Accord there's a certain
pressure now in reaction to an American
decision but we have to keep a cool head
and not let the situation escalate we
should jointly ensure our collective
security and that means preserving
Iran's presence in the agreement and
gehrig matsa standing by now where that
summit is taking place in CBU Georg we
just heard there from the French
president Emmanuel macron on Iran what
are we to make of the e u--'s joint
statement on that Sarah that message
from McCall was reiterated by a number
of other leaders who arrived here for
this informal summit the the dilemma
they all face really is that at the
decision by Tehran and the prior
decision of the u.s. Unadilla
unilaterally withdraw from the deal
really puts this diplomatic success that
the EU has achieved with the nuclear
deal into jeopardy it exposes the
diplomatic weakness if you want of the
EU because there's not a lot that a
leaders can do other than making sure
that they want to stand by the deal they
hope that Tehran may change its mind
about it and emphasizing how important
it is how much in the interests of
everyone it is to pursue a diplomatic
path to keep peace in the region and
prosperity
okay um and you know what else I'd like
to get some reaction to you you know
when it comes to the background how we
got here on this deal the difficulty for
the EU really is to find a mechanism
that would allow a business to continue
with Tehran they have created a
mechanism that involves for instance the
trade of food supplies but it does not
involve her oil supplies it does not
involve a big tech companies big
companies in Europe who are deeply
afraid of US sanctions if they were to
continue trade with Iran and that really
is the dilemma the the European Union
faces how they can resolve this in order
that you can keep enough on the table to
convince the Iranians to fulfill their
part of the deal and Garak aside from
Iran what else is at stake at today's
summit lots of unresolved issues of
course you have the migration crisis
where there's still a big router
relocation of migrants although numbers
have dropped dramatically then you have
the the reform of the euro zone
something the French president pushes
for he also will talk today to EU
leaders about the environmental agenda
and many have said he will seek to get
more other EU members to join him seeing
that the twin-engined the German French
twin engine hasn't really worked on the
big reform ideas the French president
has put forward so lots on the agenda
but also as some positive things the EU
will want to emphasize German Chancellor
Angela Merkel said we need to be
innovative we need to be strong and we
need to stick together and that is
something a lot of leaders said and
after the family picture here in CBO on
the marketplace they got a hero's
welcome from great crowds took a bath in
the crowds if you want with people
cheering the EU something EU leaders
don't experience every day
Georg mattis joining us from Romania
thank you
you